imagine you've been tasked with a really
important project at work the company
you're working for produces luxury cars
the production numbers are going down
and a lesser number of cars are getting
manufactured each day there also seems
to be an issue with the quality of the
windshield wipers that go on these cars
the question you are faced with is there
a way for the company to stop the stall
and production and increase the
production per day from 1,000 to 2,000
also is there a way to find out what's
causing the drop in the wiper quality
there is Six Sigma Six Sigma
gives you the tools and techniques to
determine what's making the
manufacturing process slow down how you
can eliminate the delays improve the
process and fix further issues along the
way the concept was introduced in 1988
by Bill Smith while working for Motorola
since then Six Sigma has seen worldwide
adoption Six Sigma aims to reduce the
time defects and variability experienced
by processes in an organization thanks
to Six Sigma you can produce a defect
free product 99.999 six percent of the
time allowing only 3.4 errors per 1
million opportunities Six Sigma also
increases customer loyalty towards the
brand improves employee morale leading
to higher productivity Six Sigma has two
major methodologists DMAIC and diem ADB
let's look at the first methodology
DMAIC is an acronym for define measure
analyze improve and control let's have a
look at each of these stages
individually and how it relates to your
earlier problem in the define phase you
determine what issues you're facing what
your opportunities for improvement are
and what the customer requires of you
here you look at the process as a whole
and determine the issues with the
manufacturing process in this case
finding out why the cars had varying
windshield wiper quality and how to
optimize the current process to
manufacture more cars in the measure
phase you determine how the
process is performing currently in its
unaltered State you determine the
current number of cars that are
manufactured in a day in the current
scenario 1,000 cars are manufactured in
a day and each of these cars are
outfitted with a pair of windshield
wipers by one of 30 machines used some
of the metrics measured or how many cars
are produced in a day time taken to
assemble a car
how many windshield wipers were attached
in a day time that takes them to do so
defects detected from each machine on
assembly completion and so on following
this in the analyze phase you determine
what caused the defect or variation on
analyzing previous data you find out
that one of the machines that installed
the windshield wiper was not performing
as well as it was supposed to production
was taking longer since the car chassis
was being moved across the different
locations slower as cranes had to
individually pick and drop the frame
this was because the wheels were
attached to the car only in the last
stage next in the improve phase you make
changes to the manufacturing process and
ensure the defects are addressed you
replace the faulty machines that
installed the windshield wiper with
another one you also find a way to save
time by attaching wheels on the frame in
the initial stages of the manufacturing
process unlike how it was done earlier
now the car can be moved across the
assembly area faster and finally in the
control phase you make regular
adjustments to control new processes and
future performance based on the changes
made the company was able to reduce
production time and manufacture about
2,000 cars a day with a higher quality
of output DMAIC is one of the most
commonly used methodologies in the world
it focuses on improving the existing
products of the organization the second
methodology is DMA TV which is short for
define measure analyze design and verify
it is used when the company has to
create a new product or service from
scratch it is also called DFS s or
design for Six Sigma
let's take the scenario where the
company decides to build a new model a
sports car in the define face you define
the requirements of the customer based
on inputs from customers historical data
industry research you determine what you
need to ensure your car becomes a
success the data collected indicates
customers are drawn to cars which can
achieve more than 150 miles per hour
customers are also more inclined towards
cars which have v6 engines and an
aerodynamic frame then in the measure
phase you use the customer's
requirements to create a specification
this specification helps define the
product in a measurable method so that
data can be collected and compared with
specific requirements some of the major
specifications that you focus on are the
top speed engine type and type of frame
in the analyze phase you analyze the
product to determine whether there are
better ways to achieve the desired
results areas of improvement are
determined and tested based on the
analysis of the prototype created in
this phase you find that the product
satisfies just about all of the customer
requirements except the top speed so
research begins on an aluminium alloy
that could possibly meet the speed
requirements of the customer following
this the design phase based on the
learnings from the analysis phase the
new process or product is designed
revisions are made to the model and the
car is manufactured with the new
material the analysis phase is repeated
based on the new design you also bring a
focus group and see how they receive it
based on their feedback further changes
are made and finally in the verify phase
you check whether the end result meets
or exceeds customer requirements once
you launch your brand-new sports car you
collect customer feedback and
incorporate it into future designs and
guess what your customers are loving the
new design
Matt is DM adv for you Six Sigma has
also found success in a number of
different industries the petrochemical
healthcare banking government and
software are some of the industries that
have utilized the concepts of Six Sigma
to achieve their business goals another
commonly used methodology adopted by
companies around the world is lean lean
is a methodology that aims to remove any
part of the process that does not bring
value to the customer it means doing
more with less while doing it better the
philosophy behind lean comes from the
Japanese manufacturing industry by Bob
Hartman who at the time was part of
Toyota since then across the world
services and manufacturing organizations
have incorporated lean within their
businesses but what if you could have
the best of both worlds a combination of
both Six Sigma and length that's Lean
Six Sigma before we get into Lean Six
Sigma we've got a quiz for you what
methodology is used by companies when
they want to release a new product
created from scratch a design measure
analyze define verify B define measure
analyze design verifying see demand
measure analyze improve control D define
measure analyze improve control leave
your answers in the comment section
below for a chance to be one of three
people to win an Amazon voucher now
let's get back to Lean Six Sigma Lean
Six Sigma is a methodology that focuses
on eliminating problems removing
inefficiencies and waste while improving
the working conditions to ensure the
customers needs are better satisfied it
combines the tools methods and
principles of lean and Six Sigma 12
another video detailing the process of
Lean Six Sigma very soon we hope you
found this informative and helpful if
you enjoyed this video please like and
share it and don't forget to subscribe
to the simply learn Channel thank you
for watching and stay tuned for more
from simply learned
[Music]
you
[Music]